I think there's a lot of social pressure
and I know for a Generation Xers like
myself that existed but now I see it for
Millennials and Gen Z this not even just
like the 30 under 30 group of people
that I mean but think about then there's
now probably 25 but we see younger and
younger people what I tell my students
is great things get into the business in
any job you can get in to pay your dues
and don't say oh within the year I've
got to be in a writers room as an
assistant because nine chances out of 10
it's not gonna happen if the lucky
chance that it happens great for you and
then bring your friends along because
really when we tell particularly grad
students on the first day of grad
schools look right and look left because
that's not just your posse those are the
people who are gonna hire you later you
know but LMU is not like other film
schools it's it's not competitive it's
more collaborative so I you know I know
USC is very competitive and I think
that's too bad because collaborative
environment is always better to nurture
other people while you're trying to get
what you want means that you'll always
have people you're working with most of
my seniors come out and they're if they
haven't changed their mind about writing
they work they're all listed this crop
of seniors that just graduated May
they're all working in the business but
will want to edit the bad stuff about
USC out of there
ya know well we see grad we can't ask
this though no schools mentioned but how
can one tell a collaborative environment
versus competitive because sometimes
competitive can mask as collaborative
and then once you've been around a
little bit you start to see no don't
care well about not just their own work
but other people's work are they
involved do they work on other people's
work I think that I think that's a big
tell and one of the teachers like one of
the what what what are your bosses like
now the difference between school and a
job is hey if your boss is an ass
there's not much you could do about that
except quit so you're gonna and it's
good for you to work for I
think because you will learn especially
early on because you will learn how to
deal with difficult people oh yeah our
life right
so unfortunately look I have to work
with Peter every day I mean yeah but you
you've asked a really nuanced question
good-o nuance because I don't I you're
making it sound like it's binary
are you collab we don't know the word
binary Peter zero zero one one no she's
thinking he means it's not one or the
other okay
I'll give my answer in I don't care I
got it I'm patient just like that if you
start speaking if you start speaking
English perhaps and so the fact is in
any environment the the difference the
places where you find that it's
competitive you'll find people being
very evaluative particularly negatively
event if that's not a good idea because
that wouldn't work because and a love
out of my butt but good ideas are always
recognized so it's always competitive
because if you have the best ideas
you're recognized as the best like LMU
is is works really hard to be a
supportive environment yet jeffrey said
here is the student who clearly was head
and shoulder above everybody else you're
going to get noticed by the quality of
your ideas so it's competitive to the
extent that you could you could stratify
who are the best of the worst writers
whether you're come you know whether
you're supportive or competitive but the
difference is the the lumps you take
along the way yeah in other words some
people again come with this idea of look
it's an aggressive marketplace we want
to prepare you for it
so if your ideas suck we're gonna let
you know it because then you won't have
so many sucky ideas later yeah as
opposed to other places I mean I know
for example people come to me all the
time with ideas saying you know can you
give me notes here's my script peers
and what I found is hard for that I
think what I find is I almost never give
criticisms what I do is I ask questions
and so if something doesn't work for me
I don't say that doesn't work or that's
no good I say have you thought about
this or why is it work to have this be
that is there another way to do that
so it's never coming out as a put-down
because people get very defensive when
you put their stuff down and I don't
want them either and I don't want to
dampen their you know their enthusiasm
and at the same point I don't think it's
helpful we're asking them
thought-provoking questions that they
can answer eventually if they're smart
enough they realize it's a criticism or
it's a flaw but it's not negative it
makes them think how do I solve a
problem so I'd like to recast it as
problem-solving you know I think it
helps to realize that believe it or not
Aaron Sorkin has written some pretty
crummy scripts and he would probably be
the first to say so so you know even the
best people are not at there but oh
there's a famous mom W Somerset mom
saying that only mediocre writers are at
their best all the time so you know I
think I think that what I try to do in
class and you know probably some of this
is influenced by Peter that it really
hurts that the compliment of music you
can see the pain in his face is miyajima
chemical never occurred to me to say to
any student and I haven't I haven't had
the experience of a student with zero
Talent I've never had that because it's
really hard to get into LM you know and
we are number eight out of ten we're in
the top ten film schools now so I plug
for LMU but even someone who was really
untalented I would probably do what
Peter just said I would probably say do
you really want to write but I would
never say you have no talent
for writing because a lot of people said
that to me they didn't say it knows
words but a lot of people discouraged me
and I think discouraging someone is
really awful it's an awful thing to do
because you never know what someone will
do later but if you let me have a little
hold on hold on I almost got a word a
stay I wasn't finished my speech I was
gonna say something nice about you if
you had told me ten years ago when I met
Peter that he was gonna write a novel I
would have said now Peter will never
write a novel that's something he
doesn't do he's not only written a novel
he's really working hard on it now you
can interrupt me I notice he didn't say
it's really good he said he's really
working it's getting there no manual or
no that historical novel which by the
way is the hardest genre there is oh
right about yeah but just you know even
when you're asked got questions I think
you have to be really careful because
questions can be very evaluative sure um
you know why did you decide to wear that
dress today it's hot the point is that's
that's the question oh yeah those
questions yes in a valuation sort and so
that's so even asking questions even
asking questions like you know why do
you want to be writing you have to be
very careful because that could be a
very discouraging question right well
I've over an evaluative question that I
would like to ask and that would be do
you think at a writer that has talent
but no connections has an easier time
getting in the business versus a writer
that has not as much talent but
connections that's a that's a trick
question because it really depends on
depends on the circle the ratios of both
yeah that's the scientific but but i but
I have to tell you contacts oh it's
really big you know they're an awful lot
of people who will never never never get
noticed no matter how good they are cuz
that's the work will just never get out
of that box true
and knowing people the big advantage but
you know we were talking about this
before today that you know the the
importance of the n-word in Hollywood
that networking is more important than
anything it's the more people you can
work with the more people you can
collaborate with um it's just when when
there's a position open in a room you're
a lot more likely to call friends you
know then just say hey we got an open
spot here come in and audition so more
work gets given to people who know
people than any other way I like what
you just said about the evaluative
questions I was I think we've all had
that happen to us in one form or another
where somebody's asking a question yeah
and then they're like I'm just asking a
question but it's the intention behind
question I had a clinical supervisor who
would really get down on me saying don't
make a statement through a question I'm
most afraid to know it's just again if I
said use the same question again you
know why did you choose to wear that
dress today right that's like saying you
know that's not really an appropriate
dress though I can tell the intention
yeah and so again it's like you have to
be careful with even when you're saying
why does your character you know why did
he choose to be a cowboy you know it's
like I'm saying that you shouldn't have
had to be a cowboy yeah I can see the
Jersey Shore possibility paying for it I
think that changes that but I mean I
think I think the important thing is
when you're asking questions to give
them the appearance of wanting
information rather than giving it
evaluations right and surprisingly
people don't really like being evaluated
negatively that much yeah that is Sonoma
is how much practice
you